avant toute chose déjà je voulais vous
je voulais vous remercier de m'avoir
invité maintenant on veut nous on veut
vraiment toutes les versions on a eu la
version du parisien ce matin qu' un
journal très sérieux avec des périodes
où vous la force du mans avoir votre
version les joueurs remercient sont
produits dans votre émission parce que
dans cette émission je crois que vous
prenez là la liberté d'expression et que
chacun peut dire ce qu'il veut et ce
qu'il pense et donc vous allez
comprendre un petit peu la complexité de
ma posture que je suis médecin etc donc
je suis soumis au secret médical sur
tout ce qui concerne les patients et je
pensais en fait à ça tout à l'heure en
disant que vous cyril si vous étiez dans
votre propre émission et que vous ne
pouviez pas fait parler ni de des buzz
venez de 2 des émissions de télé ou unis
même de vous des personnes istres avec
vous ça serait compliqué et je crois
savoir que vous avez un bavard qui est
médecin et sérieux donc c est ce que
c'est le secret médical et bien sûr que
vous allez comprendre pourquoi
effectivement si j'ai une position
difficile ce soir très bien alors on
demande qu'à voir votre version puisque
vous étiez en contact avec les patients
qui vous accuse gilles qu'est ce qui est
reproché à jamais les docteurs et
mutilations d'aidé pratique qui serait
illégale et puis d'avoir sur le plan
éthique moral brisé la vie de ces jeunes
femmes minces et ce qu elle sait ce
qu'elle indique moi j'ai une question à
vous poser vous êtes très présent sur
les réseaux sociaux ça vous a été
parfois reproché ces jeunes femmes
souvent des influences euse d'ailleurs
aussi escape à une connexion la question
et directe mais je vous la pose est ce
qu'il ya une connexion entre vie
publique et vie privée est-ce que c'est
pas des vengeances de jeunes femmes ou
de patientes avec lesquels peut-être
vous auriez été au delà de la relation
professionnelle et qui aujourd'hui
aurait envie de vous nuire
parler de vengeance par rapport à des
relations personnelles non je ne crois
pas parce que je n'ai pas de relation
personnelle avec avec mes patientes
donc
ce que je peux vous dire en fait c'est
que au travers de au travers de tout ça
et au travers de ce que j'ai vu je peux
juste vous dire en fait ce que ce que je
suis et qui je suis donc
pour lorsqu'on connaît par bain et pour
sa bomba n'a l'air dont on pourrait
penser que je suis je suis un mauvais
chirurgien pour leproux pour rappel j'ai
été j'ai été diplômé à 27 ans je suis le
plus jeune chirurgie esthétique de
france j'ai été lauréat de la faculté de
médecine j'exerce depuis 14 ans déjà
j'ai ouvert environ 450 patients par
mois ben non pas par an excusez moi
puisque je perds 40 50 à 100 par an en
moyenne et et je suis je suis membre des
soucis de la vente en france et je
communique et dans les congrès nationaux
et internationaux et je suis aussi le
chirurgien référent de l'association qui
s'occupe des ratés de logistique
française je suis le chirurgien
référence d'une association qui s'occupe
de récup de réparer les erreurs de mon
frère quand je disais ah pardon les
complications de certains de mes
confrères quelle qu'elle soit on va dire
que je ne peux pas vous en avoir mais je
suis le référent de cette association
est donc
je j'ai du mal à j'ai du mal en fait à à
reconnaître dans ces dons ce propos le
surge je suis et et surtout mêmes fins
l'homme que je suis mais alors comment
vous expliquer ces témoignages quand je
serai prêt si ya même des jeunes femmes
qui disent qu'après avoir été opérée par
vous elles ont été obligées d'aller dans
un autre hôpital pour être réparé
donc encore une fois vous savez
lorsqu'on fils messier lorsqu'on est
chirurgien quelle que soit la chirurgie
il n'y a pas de chirurgien n'y a pas de
chirurgie sans risque débattre surgit
sans complication est ce que je peux ce
que je peux dire et de manière assurée
c'est que
encore une fois j'ai dû opérer en eau
entre 5 et 6000 patients en 12 13 ans et
que effectivement on a on a toujours
forcément des petites complications des
moyennes parfois des plus importantes et
que mon travail est de vous de les
prendre en charge je suis insurgés qui
accompagnent les passants tout le temps
je ne les je n'abandonne jamais j'ai bon
je suis connecté à mon téléphone tout le
temps je je suis en vacances que je sois
que je sois à noël où tout le temps
c'est à dire que je suis joignable en
fait tout le temps et si je ne le suis
pas je suis dans un avion pendant sept
heures eh bien j'ai deux confrères qui
s'occupe de ça mais c'est à dire que mon
angoisse exempt ciel c'est justement de
ne pas de ne pas répondre à un patient
s'il a un souci je suis je suis
profondément je suis profondément
médecins autant que chirurgien et donc
non sur ça je ne je je je ne je ne suis
pas d'accord sur surnom pas sûr sûr sûr
sûr que des patientes puisse avoir des
complications et qu'elle puisse avoir un
ressenti échoit à vue parce que je
creuse je comprends leur souffrance une
patiente qui a qui a une complication et
puis parfois peut avoir entraîné des
conséquences esthétiques ou médicales
elle peut elle peut le vif très très mal
et jouets et jeux et je compatis à cette
souffrance vraiment et parfois parfois
la rue il y à un moment il ya une une
rupture qui se créent et à partir de là
eh bien eh bien les choses ne seraient
que plus de la bonne manière ce que je
trouve un petit peu enfin et même très
triste c'est que finalement ce genre de
choses se règlent au mon cabinet ou dans
un cabinet médical exercice et non pas
sur un dans la presse ou sur un plateau
télé ou sur ou sur les réseaux sociaux
et c'est ça que je joue à 16 h mathieu à
moi je doute pas deux secondes de votre
docteur juste c'est vrai que vous
travaillez beaucoup et des gens de télé
réalité est souvent j'imagine que
c'était pour de la visibilité voulait
soigner et puis que vous donner de la
visibilité sur instagram et tout ça est
ce que vous vous il n'ya pas quelque
chose là dedans qui est un peu qu'un
peut pas être ange éthiquement pour un
médecin mais tout d'un coup sur le côté
un peu pub pour la téléralité pas par an
pour la chirurgie esthétique avec des
gens de télé réalité alors en fait je
perds je perdais chez les patients de
télé réalité et je perds des patients 2
qui ne sont pas dotés l'aider des
personnes connues des personnes
inconnues et ses pertes de la même façon
qu'elles soient connues ou qu'elles
soient pas connues on m'a affublé de ce
titre de charge la télé réalité il ya xn
état quand j'ai commencé ma carrière
parce que effectivement à un moment j'ai
eu beaucoup de personnes ont été
arrêtées mais ces personnes des haltères
représente peut-être même pas je passe 0
5 % de ce que des patients du docteur
ndèye un moment elles payent ces
personnes de télé-réalité évidemment
capelli dire je fais un cadre d'un
échange marchandises il n'y a pas
d'échangé n'y a pas des champs de nom
s'il n'y a pas d' échanges de
marchandises en revanche une patiente de
t2 qui est une influence zucchi ou qui
fait la télé mais comme une patiente
langue d'affichage à cliquer quelqu'un
qui n'est pas connu si elle veut parler
en bien de moi oui elle le fasse et tant
mieux pour moi c'est bienvenu alors
comme ça qu'on se construit qu'on
devient plus grand et qu'on a plus de
passants terre il ya un code promo en
fait pour aller chez vous jamais
d'ailleurs le service vous n'avez jamais
plus je trouvais ça un nul part je n'ai
jamais fait de code promo de gaulle ce
soir donc donc non je n'y a pas d'art y
ait pas d'arrangement ce type avec le
patient daniel il n'y a pas eu
d'opération filmés alors peut-être avec
le consentement des patientes mais je
crois que c'est interdit a pas eu ça
parce qu'en fait vous parlez de
complications le risque zéro on le sait
bien n'existe pas et des complications
ça peut arriver mais mois d'après ce que
j'ai lu je vous accuse pas du tout mes
jeux juste lu l'article il ya des
pratiques quand même un petit peu limite
c'est-à-dire il ya une personne qui vous
accusent dont il restait du produit
voulu proposer de lui injecter dans des
conditions un petit peu d'hygiène limite
enfin j'ai encore une fois sont pas mes
mots ce que j'ai lu donc est-ce que ça
vous pouvez nous en parler parce que les
complications ça c'est une chose qui
peut arriver à tous les chirurgiens
l'article quand on lit ce
parti et voilà justement c'est ce que
j'ai
ils attendent notamment les personnes
qui vous dit que effectivement il y
avait une soirée à dubaï dans une villa
que dans le cadre de cette soirée vous
aviez de l'acide hyaluronique et que le
lendemain il vous en reste est et que
donc vous avez dans une chambre
lendemain
je questionne répondrai simplement la
vôtre et puis à la vôtre aussi
je suis un second 16 heures à paris les
ports je perds à paris j'ai exerçons en
france je n'ai je fais des actes de
médecine dans mon cabinet et je perds
dans deux cliniques dans les cliniques
prestigieuse donc je n'exerce aucun acte
médical quels qu'ils soient ailleurs pas
même pas même ailleurs dans la ville
mais pas même à l'étranger ni même chez
moi dire que je ne vais pas faire de
botox de botox à un chinois vous se
passe dans le cadre dans un lieu dans un
cadre médicalisé donc
encore une fois ce est-ce que vous avez
été en contact avec le confrère qui
s'est occupée de ses patientes qui
justement disait que c'était vos actes
chirurgicaux qui avait causé quelques
soucis alors d'aller à l'hôpital tenon
kadiatou alors et je vais je vais juste
je reviens sur ce que vous avez alors
quand vous avez dit qu' il y avait des
élèves et des choses qui avait été
filmée et c'est effectivement quand
j'étais un petit peu plus jeune et que
j'ai commencé à exercer eh bien il ya eu
il ya une émission télé qui m'avait été
proposé parce que j'étais plus jeune
chirurgien esthétique de france à
l'époque et donc j'avais accepté puis
eux et donc en fait un petit peu de
manière peut-être un peu trop moderne je
voulais montrer ce que c'était la
chirurgie voulons c'est le bon côté des
choses et comment c'est beau mais aussi
montrer que la chirurgie sépare jutras
est gelée peut-être effectivement
trophée et ça va a été rappelé donc
depuis je ne voyage ne filme pas pour
ceux qui me suivent sur instagram et
bien je ne ne postent des photos d'eux
avant après il n'y a pas de je ne sais
pas de jeu ne fait pas dans le dans le
sensationnel donc ça c'est pour répondre
à la question de la dola delà des trucs
télévisée effectivement c'était quelque
chose que j'ai fait jeune et que je
regrette parce que parce que je pensais
bien faire maintenant il plaque tout
c'était donc parce que dans l'article on
a les jeunes femmes et oui explique
alors c'est réparé entre l'hôpital tenon
vous avez fait mon confrère donc le
professeur accent qui est non seulement
confirmé aussi un ami donc lorsque
lorsque pour les pelles et les
influences qui y qui ont voulu enfin
cgc moi et c'est moi qui ai proposé en
fait cette prise en charge au sein du 2e
classe non par le professeur atlan pour
des raisons de haut des raisons de papa
par rapport à moi parce que je ne savais
pas le faire mais pour rendre les choses
plus faciles pour les patientes et c'est
moi qui ai fait cette démarche auprès du
professeur à temps de lui demander de
les prendre en charge guillon vous
parler de vengeance de vendetta dans le
parisien si ce n'est pas pour des motifs
personnels est ce que les femmes qui
vous accusent pourraient avoir voulu
profiter de votre notoriété parce que
vous n'êtes pas changé comme les autres
vous êtes très médiatisé vous êtes suivi
par des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sur instagram et s'il y en a
qui ont voulu profiter de vous pour
faire du buzz simplement
alors effectivement je suis un
chirurgien
médiatisée au mexique mais mais encore
une fois je rappelle ce que je suis je
suis un chien et plasticiens et celle ci
comme tous les autres chirurgiens je
fais ce métier je fais ce métier avec
mon coeur avec mon âme et avec eux
avec tout ce qu avec tout ce que je sais
faire c'est que je fais ce métier encore
une fois avec avec
avec 20 je parle pas seulement de talent
duel avec tout mon humanité d'accord et
donc lorsque effectivement et pas
lorsqu'on est médiatique des chirurgiens
qui ont des complications on en a tous
ses pores mais lorsqu'on est médiatique
et bien effectivement bas on va en plus
en parler et puis ben peut-être qu il ya
une quête de buzz je sais pas mais
baisse qui n'est pas du tout
mais pour moi on veut se venger de vous
et pour l'argent je n'en mets en fait
quoi on était pas une sorte de vengeance
c'est juste qu'il faut comprendre pour
l'instant matin dressant une personne
qui a bu une passante qui vous en veut
on sait quelles que soient les raisons
je la maison elle devrait vous en
vouloir parce que j'avais fait un beau
succès que et le sourcil qui va va qui
va descendre pendant deux mois ou aussi
parce qu'à une cicatrice et bave ou
alors parce que on peut avoir des
complications sérieuses une passion qui
vous en veux elles vont sauver après
quelques 2 de quelle manière elle avoue
en vouloir bah il peut y avoir les
années des expertises des arrangements
viable des procédures et puis ben voilà
il ya un règlement de compte via via les
réseaux et viable après si oui dans
l'article certaines patientes explique
très clairement que lorsque vous les
avez opéré vous n'étiez pas dans votre
état normal c'est ce qu'elles prétendent
et vous répondez je laisserai personne à
attenter à ma réputation est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si oui ou non vous avez
fait des opérations en étant dans un
état qui n'était pas alors je vais
en fait je suis à peu près comme comme
probablement 90 % les français voilà qui
se lèvent le matin très tôt je me lève
très tôt le matin puisque j'ai choisi un
métier où je perds à 7h30 tous les jours
je consulte à 8h30 one ouvert tous les
jours je finis à 21h moyenne au soir
donc oui franchement il ya des matins où
j'ai la tête j'ai la tête à tige et la
tête en grès quand je veux blog je ne le
coiffe pas nos coiffures les
consultations je vais fait beau mais
pour le blog je vais avoir abonnés de
cette journée est donc oui le matin je
suis pas toujours très marginaux frais
ça veut dire j'ai une tête que j'ai une
tête fatigués donc j'ai dessert je
marque est ce que j'irai opéré dans un
état second alors c'est comme si j'étais
tout seul dans une salle d'opération et
qu'il n'y a pas un anesthésiste il n'y a
pas un chef de bloc il n'y a pas une
infirmière une penseuse mon assistant
est impatient et yeux moi même je verrai
quelqu'un qui a l'air dans un état pas
normal je vous dirai pas de soucis bien
bossé et donc que personne ne vous le
dirais sauf donc c'est ces allégations
de passants qui ont eu des problèmes des
complications il un coup dit cela à la
règle il a opéré dans des conditions de
il débat dans son état normal là je peux
juste dire que malheureusement bas ce
sont les propos qui sont d'aller mieux
parce que encore une fois je pourrais
avoir été hyper facile parce que je
travaille beaucoup mais d'aller opérer
dans mon état normal n'ont pas pas
normal non pas du tout vous faites là
vous avez pratiqué sur vous la chirurgie
botox alors sur moi même nom mais par
contre j'ai fait j'ai fait un petit clip
haut en 2015